the details may be different but make no
mistake bright burn is a reimagining of
Superman's origin story asking what
would have happened to Clark Kent if the
emergence of his powers made him lose
his marbles
the answer is a lot of carnage with the
promise of more to come in the newer DC
movies Superman is known to say that the
S symbol on his chest stands for hope
that detail makes it quite chilling to
consider the possible meanings of the
symbol brand and leaves at the scene of
his crimes just like Superman's s most
obviously stands for Superman Brandin
symbol seems to be his initials brandon
breyer it could also stand for the
town's name bright burn which eventually
becomes the superhero-like name brandon
is known by but the symbol also serves
to less obvious purposes first it hints
that Brandon's instability isn't
necessarily as new to him as the
emergence of his superpowers we see the
drawing scrawled all over his notebook
suggesting he's been fixating on this
ominous symbol for a long time second it
acts as a tribute to the old comic book
trope of giving characters first and
last names starting with the same letter
or in the case of Clark Kent the same
consonant sound characters like Lois
Lane Lex Luthor Peter Parker and so on
really good alliteration you know
Brandon is entering his instant kill
mode when he slips a creepy face mask
over his head you might wonder why
Brandon does that since mask wearing is
one of the few superhero tropes who
can't trace back to Superman he's always
been more of a glasses guy while Brandon
does take some precautions to conceal
his identity that eventually seems to
have little to do with the mask when he
attacks his family members Brandon dons
the mask even though it's clear his
victims know who he is so why does he
wear it firstly it's creepy and looks
cool second Superman didn't wear a mask
and that may be the point setting
Brandon visually apart from the Man of
Steel most importantly it sets Brandon
apart from us one of the most telling
moments in bright burn comes when
Brandon tells his aunt Marilee that he's
superior his mask is his way of telling
his victims that even though he doesn't
look like an alien
he is something different and they
should be afraid why Brandon ends the
life of his father Kyle isn't much of a
mystery in a misguided effort to stop
his son before he can kill again Kyle
shoots Brandon in the back of the head
while the boy is distracted on a hunting
trip
unfortunately Brandon is as bulletproof
as his Kryptonian inspiration and
there's no coming back from that
betrayal the death of Brandon's mother
Tory is different what's most telling is
the way Brandon kills her after she
attempts to stab him with a shard of
metal from his spaceship he carries her
above the clouds and lets go allowing
her to fall to the ground and die
throughout bright burn Tory defends
Brandon in spite of mounting evidence of
his crimes even before she tries to kill
him with a weapon she knows he's
vulnerable to her words of love and
trust in him ring true Tory is the last
human brandon has any faith in even
though he knows he's literally a
different species on some level he wants
Tory to be like him perhaps so he won't
be so alone when he flies her into the
sky and lets go it can almost be seen as
a kind of test maybe he doesn't want her
to fall maybe he wants her to fly
alongside him proving once and for all
that she truly is his real mother when
she predictably plummets to her death
it's almost like a final confirmation to
Brandon of how deeply alone he is right
after killing his mother Brandon causes
a passenger jet to crash down on the
briar residence killing everyone on
board we never see exactly what he does
in his attack firstly we see the jet
heading toward him then we cut to the
next morning when FBI agents are picking
through the wreckage
Brandon is eating a cookie while resting
in the back of an ambulance looking as
innocent as can be the most practical
reason for Brandon destroying the plane
is to hide his crimes but there's also a
more symbolic reason bright burn begins
with a crash and ends with a crash when
Brandon's spaceship crashes on the briar
property in the beginning of the film a
kindly couple saves his life and raises
him as their own years later Brandon
causes a crash on the same property not
only does he not save anyone he makes
sure everyone dies it's a message to the
world that the mercy his parents showed
him when he was a baby
will not be reciprocated bright burn
ends with news reports from the
not-too-distant future showing that
Brandon's not done with this path of
destruction we see huge buildings
falling from his assaults as the news
media begins referring to the strange
flying phenomenon over bright burned by
the shortened name of simply bright burn
while the montage starts with more
traditional media outlets it ends on the
loonie fringes focusing on a video
broadcast from a conspiracy theorist
played by Michael Rooker called the big
t the program shows footage of bright
burns destruction and urges viewers to
wake up and take the threat seriously
but bright burn isn't the only threat he
mentions the broadcaster also makes
reference to a half-man half-fish entity
that's reportedly taking out boats in
the South China Sea he also tells us
about the so called witch woman who's
supposedly strangling people to death
with her rope after what we've seen at
this point it's clear that these aren't
big tease fantasies if you kept going
we'd probably hear about a half man half
bat and a man who moves so fast no one
could see him while this whole sequence
could be a setup for a sequel about a
veritable legion of real-life doom it
also works as a nod to the comics that
inspired the film more than anything it
helps to seal in bright Byrnes biggest
message that in a different light our
greatest heroes can also be our worst
nightmares check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]